if you're a fan of jordan peterson and
you're looking for ways to have a vision
schedule the life you want and not make
excuses then this video is for you
i plan each hour and i probably plan
each minute and yes it leads to way
higher productivity you need a vision of
what your life would be like if it was
just the way it should be if it was best
for you and if you were taking care of
yourself like there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at what it is
that you should be doing what's that
belief nation it seven my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift and talent
inside you that i want to see explode
out onto the world i started to mentor
me series to try to hang on people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their beliefs our
mindset their way of thinking seeps in
to us to help us become the best version
of ourselves so today we're gonna learn
from one of the best jordan peterson and
some of his best advice on how to stop
procrastinating mentor me Jordan
you
do you plan your day much or your time
generally does this lead to higher
productivity yes I plan my day
obsessively my calendar is always
absolutely full and often weeks in
advance and I plan in the morning
especially when I'm on top of things and
I plan each hour and I probably plan
each minute and yes it leads to way
higher productivity you know you you
decide what your goals are going to be
you place them in the calendar use the
calendar as your friend they because
what you want to do with the calendar is
design a day that you want to have or a
day that would be good for you and a day
that would be good for you is one that
you're that you're you know when you end
the day you feel that you've moved moved
yourself ahead towards your valued goals
and that you've kept Kaos under control
and that enables you to sleep soundly
and with a good conscience and to know
that the next day is going to be at
least not worse than that day planning
is unbelievably useful and again you
know I don't want to sound like a broken
record with regards to the future
authoring program but it really is
useful you know you need to figure out
what it is that you're aiming at and why
and then you need to figure out how
you're going to break that down over the
months and the weeks and the days but I
would approach your calendar like it's
your best friend you think okay I'm
gonna design a week man that I really
want to have and that means you can
schedule and leisure and all the things
that you want to do which what you
absolutely should do and it's also quite
fun to give yourself minimal time to do
something complicated because it's quite
challenging to see if you could do far
more than you thought in far less time
and so that's a fun game and the other
thing you can do is like if you're
avoiding something you could schedule in
five minutes of it say well like if
you're avoiding looking at some bills
because you're afraid of them you know
your first step might be to schedule in
five minutes where you just look at the
bill you don't do anything else and you
know you might be able to entice
yourself into doing that so but I would
say learning to plan is unbelievably
useful to schedule your time because
that's your life you know but schedule
the life you want that it means you have
to schedule your responsibilities often
oh
obviously because responsibilities are
those things that ruin your life if you
don't fulfill them one of the things
that can help you stop procrastinating
while let's say two things I refer to
them at the end of my talk one is how to
really nicely developed vision of heaven
it's like okay here's what you need to
know how would your life be what would
it be like if it was really good and I
don't don't get primitive about that
it's not like you know naked supermodels
on a yacht they're too skinny anyways
anyways you know what I mean it's like
yeah yeah that's I get it but it's it's
it's it's not a gap pace eh so it's it's
not sophisticated enough to be
self-sustaining it's a stupid vision and
if you pursue it it's you're just gonna
be on a sinking yacht with like
anorexics or something like that so you
need a vision you need a vision of what
your life would be like if it was just
the way it should be if it was best for
you and if you were taking care of
yourself with this thing that you kind
of described as parental love this is a
really good way of thinking about it
because it's nice and concrete so what
would be best for you three to five
years down the road if you were really
taking care of yourself like you were
someone that you thought should be
around and people are very ambivalent
about whether they should be around so
this is a lot harder than you think
so you need that vision and then what
you also need is a vision of what your
life would be like if you let yourself
deteriorate in precisely the foolish
ways that you know that you would
deteriorate if you let yourself go and
that's contemplation too it's like okay
if I let myself go where would I end up
and first of all this is kind of a
shadow realization from union
perspective it's like first of all you
could let yourself go second of all you
already know exactly how you do it if
you did do it and third with a little
imagination you can conjure up exactly
what that would be like not only for you
but for your family and for the broader
social community and that would be the
whole bloody catastrophe including all
the malevolence that would go along with
your deterioration and so on and so then
you've got these stark choices before
you one is a gap a oriented
equilibration for lack of a better
technical phrase and the other is
something that more closely approximate
hell approximates hell than people Eve
think because if you sink low enough not
only do you sink that low but you are
absolutely motivated to drag people down
there with you and it's a nasty nasty
state of affairs and so if you're really
terrified of that like you should be
because you've drawn the causal
connections and you're really attracted
by the other then when you sit down and
you don't do what you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing you don't
get to say well it doesn't matter and
that's the salience landscape issue it's
like no no no the little voice in the
back of your head that says it matters
it sees those outcomes down into the
future and it's telling you that it
matters and if you would like the
positive outcome over the negative
outcome which is like I said your
constant choice you bloody well better
sit down and do what you're supposed to
and so that's really helpful that'll I
think you know what is it fear of God is
the beginning of wisdom it's like yes
that's absolutely right and the role of
things like anxiety and terror in
promoting proper development well are
often under addressed because we think
of those things as our enemies it's like
they're they're at your enemies if you
if they're working against you but
they're pretty powerful monsters on your
side if you've got them oriented
properly I know you stated in the last
lecture that the importance for SETI
games in life and to kind of have goals
to work towards right so my question was
where do you how do you do that if you
don't know where you want to go because
that's kind of where I got stuck on
you're your future off offering program
because okay that's that's a good
question that's a really good question
so there's this notion in the Old
Testament that morality is following a
sequence of prohibitions there's a bunch
of bad things you shouldn't do and then
basically you're good enough and and and
I think there's wisdom in that I think
that's kind of where children start
right you I mean I love children and all
that but they're they're they're crazy
little creatures and they need to be you
know civilized and partly what you do is
you you lay prohibitions on them and
mostly what you're trying to do is lay
prohibitions on them for the behaviors
that if they manifested would make their
life miserable
so this is why this thing that I've said
the peoples become this crazy internet
mean but that's to clean up your room
and which which is a lot better and more
useful than people think it's a lot
harder to but the the thing the first
thing you do I think and I learned this
in part from Solzhenitsyn when he was
trying to iron out his soul when he was
in the gulag because he was trying to
figure out how he got there how he
contributed to how he got there you know
not Stellan and Hitler even though they
were kind of a blade you know but he
wasn't much he could do about that I
think what you have to do and this is
part of humility is you have to look
around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like your room put
it in order because the thing is it
isn't exactly so important that your
room is in order although it is what's
important is that you learn how to
distinguish between chaos and order and
to be able to act in a manner that
produces order and I think you can you
can do something as simple as just sit
on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things I could do
today so that tomorrow morning is
slightly better than this morning was at
least or at least I'm not falling behind
and those will usually be it's like
having to eat a toad in the morning
right it's like it's not gonna be
something you want to do there'll be
things you're trying to avoid there's
snakes essentially but if you ask
yourself like you're asking someone
which i think is a form of prayer if you
ask yourself instead of telling yourself
you know what is it that I could do to
set things more right today that I would
actually do it's usually some small
thing because he's not that disciplined
you know then you can go do it and then
you we put the world together a little
more when you do that and that spreads
out but you also put your you also
construct yourself into something that's
better able to call order forth from
chaos and that makes you just
incrementally stronger and then the next
day you can maybe take on a slightly
larger task and like you get the benefit
of compound interest if you do that it's
a tremendously powerful technique and
they think if you do that at some point
instead of just having to fix things up
that are not good you'll start to get a
glimmer of the positive things that you
could do you know the positive things
that you could do that would actually
constitute a vision and now that's what
I would recommend no one can live
without a routine you just forget that
if you guys don't have a routine I would
recommend like you get one going because
you cannot be mentally healthy without a
routine you need to pick a time to get
up whatever time you want but pick one
and stick to it because otherwise you
dis regulate your circadian rhythms and
they regulate your mood and eat
something in the morning I had lots of
clients who've had anxiety disorders I
had one client who was literally
starving very smart girl she there's
very little that she liked she kind of
tried to subsist on like half a cup of
rice a day she came to me and said I
have no energy I come home all I want to
do is watch the same movie over and over
what like is that weird and I thought
well it depends on how hard you work you
know it's a little weird but whatever
it's familiar and you're looking for
comfort so I did an analysis of her diet
it's like three quarters of a cup of
rice it's like you're starving eat
something you know you'll feel better
so she modified her diet and her all her
anxiety went away and she had some
energy it's like yeah you got to eat so
schedule that's a good thing man
your brain will thank you for it it will
stabilize your nervous system with it's
a bit of a plan that's a good thing okay
so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an an interest that's
dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed do you think well how
do I know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all the all ideas are stupid and so the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're gonna get it
right the first time is zero it's just
not gonna happen
and so then you might think well maybe
I'll just wait around until I get the
right idea
and which people do right so they're
like 40 year old 13 year olds which is
not a good idea so they wait around
until it's Waiting for Godot until they
finally got it right but the problem is
you're too stupid to know when you've
got it right so waiting around isn't
gonna help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
had there's a niche of nature called
that a will will to stupidity which I
really liked so because he thought of
stupidity as being it you know it's it's
you have to take it into account
fundamentally and work with it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps on your pathway to destiny and you
can assume that you're gonna do it badly
and that's really useful because you
don't have to beat yourself up it's
pretty easy to do it badly but the thing
is it's way better to do it badly than
not to do it at all when people are
beset with a catastrophe like let's say
the death of their father that they are
prone to use that as an excuse for not
going about the business that they
should be going about because they can
say to themselves well I would accept
and accept there's always good reasons I
mean believe me there's always good
reasons for not doing what you should
that's for sure the reasons pile up day
after day to not do what you should
especially because you're you're aiming
at things in the future you can put them
off indefinitely right because of the
demands of the day like there's no
excuse whatsoever for not getting at
what it is that you should be doing it's
absolutely reprehensible to justify your
in action with the catastrophe that
extracts mercy from other people right
there's a tricky tricky game that's
going well of course I can't do that
look at the terrible thing that's just
happened to me and see how okay I
understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current to pasture fee it's like
well actually you're not and it's rather
rude of you to use it as an excuse and
it's certainly counterproductive
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
was the single biggest takeaway that you
took from this video that you're going
to immediately apply somehow to your
life to your business to your goals let
me know leave it down in the comments
below when you write it down it's more
likely to stick with yourself as well so
I'm looking forward to hearing from you
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Oh Jay from coach dot life thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing the review on
your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book I
highly recommend you eat this book
called your one-word by Evan Carmichael
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you that sums
you Apple so it would be to like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details